morning Andy okay something is different
about my computer
aha it's gone Oh a game is the foot see
part of the police academy entrance exam
is investigating a crime so about a
month ago I told everyone in the office
that at some point they should steal
something from my desk so I could
practice let's do this
wait hey did you guys see my glasses - I
got my sunglasses - I was in Miami last
weekend I took my talents to South Beach
how do you spend your time in Miami
maybe fencing stolen computers yes I
took your government computer from
Indiana to Miami to sell it on the black
market
450 bucks haha you don't know it but you
just gave yourself away and look at your
file all day Jerry if that even is your
real name it's not my real name is Gary
well Gary if that even is your real name
somebody stole my computer now if you're
a criminal
look at me you have to tell me legally
or else it's considered entrapment I'm
sorry Andy it wasn't me oh man really
okay okay so we know it's not Jerry
unless he was lying to me I can never
tell when people are lying to me
hopefully that doesn't come up in my
police
you